welcome to this video again super cheese
super cheese seven in fact glad that's
not shoot super cheese aid right
improved version or what now okay let's
see blah come on Queens gambit declined
I have played this guy a couple of times
before check the very decent score three
wins one draw so I'm hoping tuned and
keep this keep this record well let's
say improve this record yeah white plays
on the queenside here quite obviously
going to get back with the Queen to the
one helping in defense because black
will do something here with his pieces
on the Kings side here he comes so if i
take here Queen takes but ok as it's
probably how to avoid any way ok so
night a4 to see five I guess yeah I
guess I could have gone Bishop f3 as
well provoking c6 but touch hard for
black to play without that anyway
interesting way now it's stuck roop d
895 Bishop c8 trying to keep the
queenside intact ok I'm going going here
ok so a four
the good word minority attack that's not
so easy to play this it's a kind of kind
of one-sided not that it is so great for
why do anything but it's quite
comfortable for wide to play especially
in blitz you have a ton of they are like
standard moves that you can dash out and
then send see see later about the
details however important to keep the
timing right with b5 yeah that's that's
interesting this Bishop is not very
attractive-looking so we should be three
as a move you you're not so sure about
should you play that or not I have no
great place for the for the rook though
yeah maybe that's not so bad I'm not
sure it's kind of unconventional to
trade this bishop normally you wouldn't
want to want to do that good oh that
will look something because this looks
really rotten with the beef are only
only want to take their on c5 if you
have some kind of tactic or so because
that strategically it looks very dubious
with the beep horn beep on is very weak
so let's see i have no direct tactic
maybe wants to just defend it on the
seventh-ranked that's possible so maybe
starting with this yeah he wants to
defend this with rook this the other
look coming to e7 ok ok I want to trade
quincy out quite clearly
okay so i cannot really okay maybe not
85 this yeah it's not a big deal I can
do that
this has an idea queena force my idea on
Queenie for check I've f3 I want queen d
6 year trying to trade queens I can
trade with with a check now do I want
that yes t4 as reply
I went I don't want deform
okay so he allows that kind of
surprising maybe it's so close that it
does not matter that that's possible of
course rather than that it's not
something that I would have allowed
let's say maybe g4 and then it's so
close that he will defend it I kind of
doubt that kind of doubt that how am I
going to go about it here I have to play
g4 at some point it's it's hard to do
without like here
check not going to take I'm going to try
to open this up on my terms with rook h2
Luke h1 trying at least
look H 1 and then I'm threatening to
take on g4 and okay so take g4 takes g3
group takes you four and I'm losing wow
that's kind of funny
hmm remarkable so I can take care right
i mean i can't play that then take the
fee if he takes check not did not really
see that shine coming I think I'm okay
but what's interesting
still should be a good end game I'm not
completely off here the protected if
I've pawn is quite good don't really see
what he what you should do to defend him
it's hard to overcome this kind of
problem in the Luke endgame protected
pass on e5 even here with his tactical
ideas I don't think it helped him very
much ok and I can take I can take your
first right and then aged 3 check time
morning so look here right for the pawn
ok 7 I wanted to go is six but he just
has rookie 7 of course well it's kind of
stupid I am ok it's not not at the end
of the world it's not about the porn
count but the quality here this is the
quickest or should I take this first
year actually no it's okay
oh I cannot take the look now check I
cannot take it that's kind of that's
kind of annoying promoting was check
black forfeits on time I didn't even
look at the time but to not simply
didn't look at the time yeah okay that
was interesting interesting interesting
position around here I was kind of
surprised that he allowed this structure
with with the backward beep on but it's
probably okay if you look at it I mean
he's defending it very reliably and it's
difficult for me to do something I mean
in in a situation where I have good
control I would be able to play like f3e
for ya groaning with my for he I've got
four against three like f3e for but it's
it's not so easy with the with all the
heavy pieces on and he gets in at five
to blockheads it's not so easy to
overcome that blockade I wanted to try
to trade Queens to make it more likely
that i can push the pawns hear my idea
was that after this i have f three
actually and i thought that this might
be a structure that i can play with play
against the g porn like King f2 w file
maybeee for troll is still raw but this
was was an idea at least and he hasn't I
didn't want to do that because of deform
and he's kind of breaking through so
this is why I went here to prepare that
but he didn't react at all to that he
allowed that ah hian point he has to
play G for you which I did not really
appreciate g4s good prevents this cover
now I can play this but now like here
it is this he can probably hold very
comfortably and now I'm kind of liking
my position getting some ideas check
yeah I not sure about your form it's
funnier the he has stockfish the
computer he gives h4 with 0.7 and okay
how do we ever win if I it just do
nothing that's a complete draw their
computers they they very often still
have their problems with with fortresses
and this is a total fortress okay of
course I don't do that go here I know
edge for computer says dead equal maybe
but we're going to see how it comes she
takes it takes and now John comsys rook
takes a three okay check check here I ok
now can understand you this is infected
wrong I was thinking I can just go here
but of course he plays that that and
just just go check and if I go to the
King opponent yeah oh sorry if I go yes
this movie with counter play now do you
have to be precise I mean here I'm
already not so sure he has to do
something active like that but I don't
know that this looks super wide here you
can hear you can probably improve
somehow this was almost losing a temple
but probably not so not so terrible e 6
I don't like don't want to trade stuff
he sixes the comp move but it isn't this
strong I thought it was strong actually
cutting away the king and he takes time
for him like this and now i'm running
running with my king and computers not
agreeing at all hmm
I rock g7 that sets a dead severe that's
a problem hmm so I should not run with
the King actually but play rook f6 yeah
let sets in fact stronger this is now
I'm getting the two passes now okay it's
even winning i guess the compass on + 2
+ 3 and climbing the pawns will run I
didn't they I didn't think of route 27
here Kate was Sir of course the time
issue but I'm surprised that the
computer still thinks that this is a
draw maybe it needs to calculate deeper
I can't believe that with the pawn seven
so that loses okay rupee eight is
supposed to be a draw really I hear that
rook c8 so in 73 OOP teammates II to
Queen and yeah okay that's probably
probably perpetual yeah it wasn't so
easy it wasn't so easy yeah ultimately
he faulted with no time on the clock but
as mentioned it was a tricky endgame so
tough to play with you all the time okay
thanks for watching